la globalizzazione è evidentemente una
cosa che non la possiamo fermare ma ha
un impatto molto grande e io credo che
al di là di tutta la politica che il
governo fano e tutto è responsabilità di
ogni cittadino per fare un po su tutto
questo e non solo sulla globalizzazione
ma soprattutto questo quelli problema è
che siamo avendo adesso per esempio
parlando di countdown il cibo che in
italia molto importante per voi avete
una non solo si mangia perché piace ma
si mangia come stilo contraddizione il
territorio eccetera allora io credo che
è importante fare un po il link con
questo diciamo il cibo il settore del
cibo e tutta la sua produzione più o
meno contribuisce con 26 per cento a
delle emissioni globali e nel male
stesso tempo è sicuramente il cibo e
response è fondamentale per tutti i
paesi tutte le colture e lillo e la
globalizzazione ha un problema che
adesso stavo cominciando a mangiare un
solo tipo di mais dello stesso colore da
per tutti i paesi del mondo e lo stesso
con tutto e questo è un risultato della
globalizzazione è buono non è buono per
noi non è buono perché noi siamo come
tutti diciamo se sorsi noi siamo una
parte un membro di queste pianeta la
natura stato lì noi siamo venuti ma noi
non stiamo rispettando a tutti i membri
di questo mondo come animali le piante e
tutti lì fuori c'è una biodiversità
molto grandi e per quello che ogni paese
aveva il suo proprio cibo aveva la sua
forma di mangiare aveva il suo prodotti
che c'è per adesso perché siamo sempre
stiamo cercando di guadagnare di più
sempre stavano vedendo il business su
tutto
stiamo provando da fare mangiare a tutti
lo stesso e quella è una cosa che noi
siamo incontra perché perché va incontro
anche della natura e io credo che tutti
il problema attuale sono perché noi non
rispettiamo la natura la soluzione sono
e la natura e noi dobbiamo fare un mix
della natura per fare è trovare le
risposte allora sì produrre il cibo
contribuisce 26 per cento alle missioni
che contribuiscono al cambiamento
climatico
il clima cambia naturalmente però noi lo
stiamo facendo più veloci queste per
cento percentuale di emissioni che sono
per produrre il cibo
però dopo viene le spreco del cibo 30
per cento del cibo che se produce per
mangiare viene sprecato non solo di ogni
persona che al tavolo e forse non mangia
e dopo lo vota però la catena dei
supermercati perché c'è le scadenze
eccetera
e questo genera ancora emissioni tante
missioni che vuol dire che per produrre
un chilo di qualche se ci vo
ho bisogno di acqua ho bisogno dei
nutrienti che sono e nel suolo
ho bisogno di un investimento
fertilizzanti e questo quando sepla
industria quando produce fertilizzanti e
fa emissioni allora è tutto un circolo e
quello ovviamente ha un impatto
economico perché più o meno con queste
spreco se perde 750 miliardi di dollari
all'anno
allora è tanto solo in italia sono 13
miliardi di dollari che se perdono il
prete spreco ma da dove viene il cibo 95
per cento del cibo e prodotto nel suolo
e adesso sono in tutto quello del
countdown e tutor non abbiamo sentito
quasi mai una soluzione che il suolo e
le dico velocemente di tutto il carbonio
che c'è e l'atmosfera più o meno sono
840 giga toni
the carbon in atmosfera sono 640 più o
meno e la vegetazione in una foresta il
suolo e nel primo 30 centimetri a 694 se
andiamo a tre metri avevamo 2400g
gattoni che vuol dire che sì noi no
facciamo un buon uso di queste suolo
tutto questo e carbonio può andare
all'atmosfera e li staremo parlando non
saremo parlando saremo piangendo perché
veramente sarà un cambio drammatico
allora quando tutti parlano di
decarbonizzare l'economia una soluzione
molto pratica si è giusy carbonizzare al
suolo perché con tanto russo che se
hanno fatto nell'agricoltura
abbiamo perso tanto abbiamo fatto tante
emissioni di carbonio
ma adesso parliamo solo del carbonio ma
c'è un altro elemento molto più
pericoloso che si chiama e sotto mi
sembra che in italiano
il fertilizzante a del software per più
usato nel mondo io in tanti suoni non
abbiamo bisogno però continuiamo usarlo
e questo quando va l'anno spera perché
quando quando il contadino fa
l'applicazione solo un po rimane lì il
resto va l'atmosfera quello è difficile
che catturarlo e metterlo di novoli
rimani lì e contribuisce a tutto quello
che è la capa de possono allora stiamo
parlando di una soluzione che può
aiutare perché perché è facile di tutti
i posti spreco di cibo doveva vanno a
posti che fanno del fiuto e se mischia
con tutto e li abbiamo emissioni di
metano ancora più difficile però questo
potrebbe andare di nuovo al suolo como
facendo un composto ma quello si chiama
la gestione del rifiuti ma non lo stavo
facendo
allora ce l'hanno tanta e soluzione che
noi possiamo fare ma tutti noi
tante volta siamo un po egoista perché
pensiamo adesso ognuno ognuno siamo
individualisti non viviamo più in
comunità non pensiamo più
e non e tanti diciamo a che il governo
che che sindaco ma noi dobbiamo
cominciare a fare qualcosa con le spreco
non evitando quello non comprare troppo
eccetera perché stiamo contribuendo di
una maniera che non va bene allora il
cambio climatico è una realtà
la sostenibilità è molto importante ma
dobbiamo fare e per quello tutti
dobbiamo prendere un po diciamo
decisioni e azioni
il contadini sono lì pronti per fare
qualcosa di meglio ma qualcuno le deve
dire perché loro possono cambiare la
forma in che fanno l'agricoltura
sì qualcuno legga un supporto tecnico se
qualcuno le da incentivi per farlo e
così possiamo evitare emissioni e
possiamo catturare di più quello è che
stiamo provando di fare è sicuramente
credo che può contribuire un po in
questa lotta
grazie